c'est un fleuron de la pêche
industrielle française qui appareille
dans le port de dieppe en cette matinée
du 14 février 1986 la campagne va durer
40 jours
le bateau un chalutier usine sur lequel
le poisson est conditionnée prêts à la
vente quand il est débarqué et flambant
neufs mises à l'eau il ya quelques mois
seulement que ce n'est qu'un arc tic
doit se rendre à l'ouest de l'ecosse à
plus de quatre jours de mer
la zone est riche en ligne bleue la
julienne un poisson de profondeur qui se
pêchent par plus de 700 mètres de fond
à bord 27 marins
un capitaine claude jouant et son second
le fils de bernard mallet william ces
hommes travaillent depuis longtemps
ensemble ils ont déjà affronté des mers
difficiles et des situations de pêche
délicate
le temps du voyage est mise à profit
pour les derniers préparatifs
une fois sur la zone de pêche le rythme
est soutenu l'équipage est payés au
rendement
sur le pont les hommes vont se relayer
12 heures de travail six heures de repos
il faut rentrer avec les cales pleines
400 tonnes de poissons
le poisson est traité sous le pont
supérieur dans la partie usines du
bateau
seuls les filets sont conservés
le reste tête écailles peau est rejetée
à la mer par une sorte de petite trappe
invite déchets dont la commande emmanuel
quatre jours après avoir quitté dieppe
le snekkar arctic arrive sur la zone de
pêche
autour de lui treize autres bateaux
français le vent se lève force 7 rien
d'anormal à cette époque de l'année en
mer du nord
dans la soirée du 20 février l'équipage
de nuit monte sur le pont
les marins d'astreinte à l' usine
attendent la relève pour aller dormir
charles d'arrêt le cuistot vient de
terminer son service
sur le coup de 11 heures du soir on a le
bateau accroché
le bateau accroché le chalut d'heure on
accrochée au fond soit quelque chose le
patron s'est mis a filé du câble une
manoeuvre de façon à se décrocher du
fond parce qu'il vous pour perdre son
matériel s'est appuyé sur le sur
l'arrière du bateau et une vague un
paquet de merck est arrivé là dessus ka
ka nous voyait le pont d'abord ça y
avait tellement d'eau et on a peut-être
eu 45 ans tom ou 80 tonnes d'eau sur le
pont et donc j'ai refermé mon igloo il y
avait un peu d'eau dans la cuisine jeux
comme gta sera regardé la télévision en
ce moment là j'avais donné un petit coup
de toile puis
voilà et puis je suis retourné au regard
des monts mon film de genre d'annoncé
des deux heures moins le quart avant
jésus christ le fils salomon sous
lurette ou de ma vie et puis voilà la
fin du film je suis je vais me coucher
il était sur le coup de minuit
quand charles d'arrêt se réveille le
cauchemar du snekkar arctic a déjà
commencé
mon bras s'enfonçait dans le bois parle
par l'âge et au
genou là je me réveille je rallume la
lumière je sors d'un jeu sauf de ma
cabane parce qu on appelle ça la cabane
lit ou c'est qu'on couche je me retrouve
déjà avec les pieds sur la cloison
bourges
je dis ça y est on en train de couler
j'appelle le mécanicien allemange deroff
dépêche toi on coule
entre 23 heures et 2 heures du matin les
fans vont se multiplier
c'est d'abord le tableau électrique
situé sous la bouche d'aération qui
disjonctent lorsqu un paquet de mer
envahit le bateau plus de courant trois
des quatre pompes qui servent à évacuer
l'eau d'embarquer quand les chaluts sont
remontés cesse de fonctionner
lévitte déchets sont restés ouverts
désormais la mer peut s'y engouffrer
alourdis et déséquilibré le snekkar
arctic penche dangereusement sur tribord
il ne se relèvera pas charles d'arrêt a
à peine le temps d'enfiler sa
combinaison de survie moi je suis parti
ap par l'eau et puis bah je flottais je
me tenais à montbard au chaud flottait
puis comme j'ai vu qu'
il y avait assez de assez d'eau jeudi il
faut que je lâche le bateau parce que
moi je vais me faire fracasser par par
les paquets de mer or j'ai lâché ma main
et puis je suis parti comme ça j'ai
monté à cinq mètres en hauteur 5 6 m en
hauteur la dernière vision que j'ai
cessé l'étrave du bateau avec le bel et
qu'il s'enfonce en moins d'une heure le
snekkar arctic disparaît 18 mar en
manque à l'appel le cuistot charles
d'arrêt ne reverra plus jamais son ami
rolf le mécanicien le bateau emporte
avec lui une partie des espoirs de toute
une région
[Musique]
18 marins français sont portés disparus
après le naufrage de leur chalutier
comme snekkar arctic un bateau de dieppe
neuf survivants ont été recueillis par
des bateaux de pêche qui se trouvaient
dans les parages
au lendemain du naufrage dieppe et ses
environs se réveille sous le choc la
nouvelle de la disparition du snekkar
arctic fait l'effet d'une bombe
le surlendemain les rescapés sont
rapatriés en france et les langues se
délient les premières questions se
posent comment un bateau aussi moderne
que le premier ministre de l'époque
laurent fabius avait surnommée la rolls
royce de la mer at il plus coulé aussi
vite
et pourtant l'histoire du snekkar arctic
avait si bien commencé
il fait partie d'une série de trois
bateaux identiques tous les trois
assemblées chez ac m les ateliers et
chantiers de la manche
la ville de dieppe et la région se sont
battus pour obtenir le contrat de
construction une bouffée d'oxygène au
moment où les chantiers navals sont en
difficulté un peu partout en france en
ce début des années 80
les subventions affluent c'est de bonne
augure pour le secteur de la pêche
industrielle locale
guy lengagne est alors secrétaire d'état
à la mer dans le gouvernement de laurent
fabius il se souvient du contexte de
l'époque j'ai pas gardé le souvenir
d'une période calme pas du tout du tout
parce qu'il ya eu quand même globalement
contenu la diminution des ressources
et/ou quand même globalement une
diminution constante des apports de
pression en france donc ça se traduit
par moins de bateaux donc moi d'homme à
homme embarqué
dieppe comme les autres ports affronte
la crise de la pêche en france en une
dizaine d'années près des deux tiers des
marins pêcheurs perdre leur emploi
l'entrée dans l'union européenne de
l'espagne du portugal ne va pas arranger
la situation
les deux pays possèdent une tradition de
pêche et de nombreuses unités qui
lancent leurs filets dans les mêmes eaux
que les pêcheurs dieppois à la recherche
des mêmes poissons
la concurrence est rude elle déstabilise
le monde fragile de la pêche
jambou fils était à l'époque adjoint au
maire de dieppe il se souvient de ses
années de crise pour la pêche
les chantiers navals on est à la pleine
période en 82 83 84 houle l'industrie
navale en france pas seulement à des
actes mais en france on connaît ses
problèmes où la plupart des bateaux sont
construits en pologne sont construits
ailleurs
et donc il ya une sorte de mobilisation
locale
qu'elle d'ailleurs je participe pour
dire il faut que ces bateaux soient
construits à dire parce que il ya un
chantier naval jeu plus combien est à
l'époque mais peut-être 300 bonhomme et
que si on n'a pas le marché des bateaux
et c'est quand même un bon marché
puisque c'était trois bateaux à
construire peut-être 20 2 84 86 et trois
années de lancement donc c'était du
travail sur une
une longue période pour beaucoup de
simples beaucoup de salariés donc
c'était économiquement pour la pour la
place de dieppe quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et c'est même
pour cela mon avis que ces bateaux ont
été très largement subventionnés quand
un armateur payer un euro enfin l'époque
un franc bien il fallait que l'état
mette un franc
en remportant l'appel d'offres pour la
construction de trois nouveaux bâtiments
les chantiers offre à la ville de dieppe
500 emplois un véritable signal de
redémarrage industriel
snekkar le nom de valeureux guerriers
vikings donner aux chalutiers est un
présage de bonnes pêches et de réussite
le steak art nordique est le premier à
être mis à l'eau en 1982 suivi par le
sne écart arctique inauguré en 1984 en
1987 viendra le tour du snekkar
denis châteaulin était alors journaliste
à france 3 régions il se souvient que le
snekkar arctic faisait l'objet de
nombreux reportages sur les mérites
technologique du bateau
le seul espoir c'est enfin c'est comme
ça que j'avais perçu à l'époque
il n'y avait pas d'avenir au 201 bateau
aussi moderne que ça c'est les petits
bateaux ne pouvait pas aller sur zone
quand il rentrait le poisson n'était pas
en très bon état
salé ou y avait pas de solution alors
que la congélation avec des fours donc
congélation avec saisie rapide c'était
vraiment la solution c'est comme si le
poisson vous aviez de votre assiette il
sortait de la mer un quart d'heure avant
en terme de qualité
du poisson c'est vraiment ça c'était
vraiment une une innovation profonde à
ce moment là
en novembre
1984 l'inauguration du snekkar arctic
est un événement à la mesure des
espérances que suscite le bateau élus
journalistes se pressent autour
d'edouard leveaux l'armateur
la famille leveaux est une vieille
famille dieppoise le grand père était
déjà un des plus grands armateurs de la
côte normande
le petit fils édouard fait fructifier
l'héritage il deviendra également maire
rpr de la ville quelques années plus
tard
[Musique]
à
franck boîte elle est journaliste dans
la presse quotidienne régionale il a
couvert l'histoire du snekkar arctic
depuis la mise à l'eau du bateau
ce bateau magnifique avec un équipage
qui avait été quand même triés sur le
volet à bateaux neufs qui représente un
investissement considérable pour un
armement vous pensez bien qu'on va pas
le confier à n'importe qui donc ont
choisi les meilleurs ont choisi des
meilleurs et donc l'accident en était
d'autant plus incompréhensible
le snekkar arctic a été conçu pour de
longues campagnes en mer
l'ensemble du bâtiment fait 80 mètres
dans le plan initial de l'architecte
mais cette longueur lui ferme bon nombre
de zones de pêche il faut donc repenser
le bateau il est raccourcie de 30 mètres
par l'arrière sans pour autant modifier
le blocus sinn
le canada a fixé la limite à 50 mètres
la longueur ne devait pas excéder 50 m
donc ces bateaux-là ont été raccourcis
pour pouvoir entrer dans les eaux
territoriales canadiennes et péché
notamment la morue des poissons de
profondeur mais
peut-être mais là je ne suis pas un
spécialiste maritime non je ne
m'avancerai pas qu en raccourcissant la
longueur du bateau on n'en modifie aussi
l'a6 où la stabilité
la pression économique est trop forte
pour renoncer à de riches zones de pêche
une trentaine de mètres en moins pour
quelques dizaines de tonnes de poissons
en plus le calcul est simple
il faut savoir que les eaux qui se
trouve à l'ouest de l'ecosse et
au sud du canada enfin sud est du canada
sont très poissonneuses c'est dire qu'il
ya vraiment beaucoup de poissons les
eaux sont froides profonde et il y a
beaucoup de poisson de qualité mais ces
dépêches de grande profondeur puisque le
il pêche à la ligne bleue qui se pêche
je crois au delà de 700 mètres de
profondeur donc entre 700 et 1000 mètres
de profondeur donc ça veut dire des
couches à lui très long avec beaucoup de
câbles beaucoup de danger parce
qu'apparemment davy d'autant de longueur
ça pose problème
pour prendre de la lingue bleue le
snekkar arctic doit lancer plus d'un km
de fils et de câbles en mer une
opération qui peut être dangereuse par
gros temps sur un bateau raccourci le
risque d'instabilité et grands
[Musique]
où était le filet la nuit du drame les
manoeuvres du capitaine ont-elles été
entravée d'autres bateaux pêchent autour
du snekkar arctic c'est le seul espoir
pour les neuf marins qui ont pu
s'extraire du chalutier il flotte dans
leur combinaison de sauvetage et
attendent qu'on vienne les chercher
plus de deux heures me croyant seul
survivant entre entre les creux des
vagues on les voyait on voyait les
bateaux il y avait chaque mois
si sept bateaux et j'étais étonné qu'une
fois qu'on était dans l'eau enfin que
j'étais dans l'eau que les bateaux
faisait part aux deux journaux que je
voyais bien qu'il continuait leur pêche
jean-claude bellamy était alors
capitaine du dogger bank un des
chalutiers travaillant le plus près du
snekkar arctic c'est par hasard que son
regard s'est arrêté sur de petites
lumières qui flottait dans l'eau
je voyais ne voyez plus c'était une
guerre qui est une idée comme ça donc
j'ai pas dire et j'ai beau bateau là
dessus pour pas risquer de choquer
quelque chose à l'aise un moment
j'ai vu un bateau arrivé sur nous
c'était le 2 guerres banque
le dogger banque recueil à son bord neuf
marins du snekkar arctic
mais pendant la manoeuvre de secours il
perd un de ses hommes emportés par une
meurtrière de la mer du nord
le capitaine bellamy et c'est encore de
retrouver des survivants
mais dans la matinée du 21 février tout
espoir est abandonné l'eau est trop
froide pour survivre tous les bateaux
stoppent leurs recherches
le dogger banque met le cap sur l'île
lewis pour y débarquer les naufragés
d'où ils seront rapatriés vers la france
[Musique]
denis châtelain aurait dû embarquer sur
le sne et kara arctique lors de cette
marée mais au dernier moment son
rédacteur en chef a annulé son départ
[Musique]
pour moi une des images les plus
marquantes c'était quand les rescapés
sont sont rentrés sont sortis du bus je
crois que je n'oublierai pas cette image
quoi c'est vraiment
des visages est un des regards fuyants
personne qui voulait parler personne
n'avait rien à dire je crois qu'il ya
que le cuisinier qui a voulu accepter de
donner quelques maux et
qui a dit que tout est allé très vite je
me souviens que de ça mais je
ne peux pas oublier cette scène quoi
bernard mallet lui non plus n'oubliera
jamais son fils william était second sur
le sne écart arctique ancien marin il
connaît la mer et les risques qu'elle
comporte il a voulu comprendre ce qui
s'est réellement passé cette mais là il
n'accepte pas la fatalité
il a fait de cette quête le combat d'une
vie
vous avez un naufrage
c'était la faute à pas de chance parce
qu'un marin était fait pour mourir en
mer
mais elle amère
elle est pas responsable est responsable
de rien la mer c'est un élément c'est un
élément qui est dangereux
les marins le savent d'ailleurs
puisqu'ils prennent à ses précautions et
ils savent travailler à la mer seulement
quand vous avez des marins qui partent
sur un bateau en toute confiance était
qu'on leur donne un sabot en fer à
repasser
là la mère à l'enfant et puis c'est tout
mais c'est pas la mer qui est
responsable c'est le sait les gens ont
construit ce bateau là c'est les gens
auront envoyé à tous leurs mais qui sont
des assassins
pour guy roux l'ancien directeur des
chantiers à cm qui ont construit le
bateau une erreur de conception est
inenvisageable
on a dit beaucoup de choses sur les
faits tellement mais là partie adverse
je comprends ils ont souffert énormément
donc c'est normal la réaction est
normale maintenant il faut quand même
savoir qu'un bateau on construit pas un
bateau comme ça c'est régi par des
règles extrêmement strictes ses
internationales il ya des surveillantes
du bureau veritas l'administration aussi
on laisse pas partir un bateau-mère
s'ils ne répondent pas tassement à tous
les feux verts les marais n'avait pas
confiance sur ce bateau je sentais
acheter c'est vrai on met quelqu'un à
marin aguerri sur un bateau il va sentir
son bateau il va pas le sentir il
n'avait pas confiance on se bat au tout
de suite et son livre on a des problèmes
on sent pas bien ce bateau la priorité a
été donnée à la rentabilité du bateau
plutôt qu'à sa stabilité ou même sa
sécurité
d'abord le l'armateur lui même le mot a
dit en public
je n'ai pas en nous n'avons pas fait un
bateau usine nous avons construit un
bateau autour d'une usine c'est donc les
principales choses c'est l usine c'était
le pognon c'était le leur le pognon et
oui ils étaient sales à la vie d'un amas
comprend
jamais d'un homme à compans
le fils de bernard william maleh avait
27 ans au moment du naufrage il était
père de trois enfants
le jour que mon fils
a disparu on n'a jamais retrouvé
j'ai juré sur la tête
que je me battrai jusqu'au bout
face au combat d'un homme qui veut
comprendre l'armateur le constructeur
mais aussi le bureau veritas l'organisme
qui a homologué le bateau présentent un
front commun pour eux le naufrage est dû
à une erreur humaine il tente de faire
porter la responsabilité du drame
capitaine et à son équipage
comme dans tout accident on peut jamais
qui peut y avoir une erreur et j'ai dit
à la fin il ya peut-être une erreur
humaine est à profaner le sur roddick
c'est une erreur humaine s'en prendre à
l'équipage aux marins elle même la thèse
est insupportable aux yeux des victimes
c'est un manque de respect un manquement
un code d'honneur alors même que les
familles ne peuvent pleurer leurs morts
disparus en mer pour certains
[Musique]
devant la justice les familles entendent
se battre ensemble elle imagine déposé
une plainte commune devant le procureur
de la république mais la loi française
al'inverse de ce qui se pratique aux
états unis avec des class actions
n'autorise pas ces regroupements de
victimes chaque famille doit déposer une
plainte à titre personnel bernard mallet
les regroupent et fonde l'association
des familles de victimes du snekkar
arctic moins de deux mois après le
naufrage
françois garreaud elle de ses premiers
avocats
là où nous rejoint la 'class action'
c'est précisément dans le rôle
particulier de monsieur mal et qu'il
faut vraiment saluer parce que il a été
le fédérateur et il a été celui qui n'a
jamais démordu après avoir formé cette
association nous sommes allés à au
palais de justice de dieu et nous avons
partait plate dans l'opinion des
familles des victimes au moins et dont
l'opinion dieppoise assez vite
clairement ce n'était pas que la faute à
la fatalité le premier réflexe ça a été
les marins n'ont commis aucune faute
c'est une question de dignité de le
faire reconnaître et à partir de ce
moment là nous allons battre pour
démontrer qu'il n'y a pas de fautes chez
nous et qui à la faute chez les autres
les autres concepts vérificateur
armateurs le combat est inégal face à
l'association des familles des victimes
les mis-en-cause s'emploie pour faire
pression sur la justice
premier manquement à une procédure qui
ne fait que commencer un enquêteur est
nommé spécialiste des questions de pêche
c'est henri poisson
celui là même qui avait délivré le
certificat de navigabilité du snekkar
arctic il devient ainsi juge et partie
normal on aurait bien un administrateur
de boulot comme ça bon c'est normal mais
là
mais
celui qu'a suit dé la construction
qui a donné toutes les autorisations
bateaux de naviguer
et celui qu'on met pour juge st
s'il a commis des fautes lui
on a commis on est sur on éprouve qu'il
était là comme des pauvres bon s'il a
commis des fautes
il va pas dire oui je reconnais que j'ai
connu que les fautes il va dire non
c'est pas moi c'est lui c'est lui qui a
mal
qu'ils savaient pas au milieu du bateau
c'est lui qui a précisé louis kemp a
fait ça c'est les mécaniciens pour pc
35 plaintes sont déposées devant le
tribunal de grande instance de dieppe
les familles de victimes espèrent que
des responsabilités seront prouver et
des coupables punis
elle entame également une procédure
civile pour dédommagement
l'instruction va durer sept ans sept ans
de confrontation de consultation et
d'audition les trois mises en examen
sont guy roux le directeur des chantiers
assez m jean bourrel responsable du
bureau veritas qui a homologué le bateau
et henri poisson le représentant des
affaires maritimes de dieppe
l'administration de tutelle
ils vont tenter de minimiser la portée
du procès à venir mais le naufrage du
snekkar arctic a déjà marqué les esprits
des habitants de la région
christian cuvier était maire de dieppe
il se souvient des pressions exercées
sur les familles de victimes les
survivants ont tout de suite été si
j'ose dire pris en charge par les
autorités que ce soit l'armement que ce
soit d'autre d'autres personnes de telle
manière que
leurs intérêts matériels soient
préservés et qu'en même temps
leur demande de ne pas être des
accusateurs ou de transformer de
participer à une campagne quelconque de
dénigrement de ce qui faisait la force
de l'armement et et de ceux qui avaient
construit des bateaux et de ceux qui
avaient vérifié l'état des bateaux en
fin de toute la chaîne des gens qui
pouvaient être mis en cause dans
la défaillance du bateau
le veau est venu nous voir sortie de
l'avion sur le tarmac pour nous dire
qu'elle est plat de journalisme
qui nous attendait dans l'aéroport
pressez pas discuter avec eux voilà
point par point l'association des
familles de victimes et bernard mallet
vont s'efforcer de répondre aux
accusations portées contre l'équipage
notre objectif était très clair il était
de faire reconnaître que les victimes
étaient des victimes et uniquement des
victimes de faire reconnaître qu'il n'y
avait par conséquent aucune
responsabilité avérée pour ce qui
concernait le capitaine du navire et
pour appuyer sur les fautes et les
responsabilités qui avait amené à ce
naufrage
au centre des débats le capitaine du
snekkar arctic claude jouant il aurait
remis le chalut à l'eau alors que le
bateau connaissais déjà quelques avaries
et aurait continué la pêche malgré les
pannes électriques
ils ont remis le chalut à l'eau donc
pendant une heure ils ont essayé de
réparer ce petites avaries
pendant une heure le bateau a continué
et ce bateau a même coulé tous feux
allumés donc il avait encore tout son
courant électrique dont on a un petit
peu dit rapidement le bateau était
désemparé sens plus rien c'est pas vrai
le bateau a continué à travailler le
patron du bateau a décidé de remettre
son chalut à l'eau donc on peut
considérer quand même que si on revient
à chaque du halo c'est que tu pas que
tout va bien mais qu' on peut le faire
ça veut dire que open de sécurité le
patron avait jugé qu'il pouvait remettre
son chalut à l'eau est ce que le patron
a pris fait prendre plutôt des risques
inconsidérés à son navire donc aux
hommes parce qu'il fallait absolument
qu'on pêche c'était ça la question qui
était posée au départ est ce qu il ya
une faute quelque part qui te prévenir
il aurait pas du péché on aurait pu se
poser la question quand il a vu que la
gîte prenez comme ça c'est
sûrement ce qu'il a fait dans sa tête il
a voulu revenir et son chalut pour
pouvoir avoir la possibilité de mieux
manoeuvrer
et puis en fin de compte quand il a
reviré son chalut il a dû en virée 200 m
ou 3 cents mètres de câbles et comme
là au niveau de la machine c'est assez
des
atouts le
tout le club est reparti à la mer
jusqu'à était plus un morceau de
capsules treuil
c'est à la fois de train de marcher tout
seul et toutes ouvertes est tous les
corps parfait la mer avec le chef
qu'elle entraînait puis toute façon pour
y jouer pu manoeuvrer le bateau c'était
fini des escrocs on était trop trop
plein d'eau quoi autre point soulevé par
l'instruction ou qu'un signal de
détresse n'aurait été lancé par
l'équipage du snekkar arctic
pas demandé des heures comme
savais que j'étais là il y avait un
autre collègue qui était à même distance
mais sur la sur saône arrière qui
pouvait être là encore plutôt parce que
songe à lui était à bas par aborder dire
devenir mois à la limite d'assister s'il
ya besoin ou pas assisté mais même que
ce qu'on serait approché prêts à
intervenir s'ils avaient eu besoin on
aurait peut-être récupérer 5 6 je ne
sais pas cette bonhomme j'en serai de
plus on aura récupéré de plus ça c'est
certain
l'histoire du patron
qui n'a pas envoyé de sos la mois déjà
ils m'ont dit nous on était quand on est
resté à l'eau on a vu le bateau coule et
on a vu le patron de la radio en train
de se débattre dans la passion qu'ils
pouvaient pas monter parce qu'ils
étaient acculés dans leur
élan et qu'il ne pouvait pas bouger et
ont ils ont les a vu couler l'a dit lui
a peut-être pensé s'en sortir tout seul
le puits
parce qu'en plus de ça il y avait quand
même le second
williams malek était là il y avait juste
à dire ben ça va pas aux demandes
d'assistance l'ont pas fait pour qui et
pourquoi je ne peux pas vous dire
l'enquète met aussi à jour le fait que
personnes à bord ne savait utiliser les
combinaisons de sauvetage des
combinaisons qui était pourtant au
centre des préoccupations du secrétaire
d'état à la mer de l'époque guy lengagne
chez moi qui avait pris un arrêté sur
les combinaisons de chirurgie
professionnels avaient mis au point une
commision survie qui permettait à la
fois de flotter et qui permettait de
résister au froid c'est quand même
effectivement un élément de sécurité
importantes pour les marins et je vais
été convaincus du franchement qu'il
fallait rendre sa obligatoires s'est dit
pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi y at il eu tant de morts les
gens n'ont pas su la plupart du temps
mettent leur combinaison de survie mais
ceux qui ça s'est vérifié ce qu'ils ont
réussi à l'aneth ceux là ont eu la vie
sauve
là les gars
sont sur un bateau de pêche
et ils travaillent 18 heures par jour
vous entendez bien
18 ap alain par jour croyez vous qu'ils
ont tant de faire des essais de
nom on aurait dû prendre une journée
avant de lancer le bateau à la mer pour
apprendre aux garçons servir alors là
dessus l'administration maritime et tout
ce qu'il faut dire que le moment est ce
que ça relève du commandant est ce que
ça relève de l'armateur de faire faire c
c'est cette combinaison
parce qu'on avait fait l'armement du
bateau qui était tout neuf on a été
longtemps aura mis plus d'une dizaine de
jours pour faire un moment on aurait pu
faire un essai à terre année c'est la
terre avec une combinaison ça n'a jamais
été fait et c'était exactement pareil
peu spécial suspect car comme je vous
dis c'était soit autres bateaux pareil
seuls quelques marins avaient procédé à
des essayages de combinaisons
le cuistot charles d'arrêt et de cela
les jambes j'arrive pour passer le temps
j'enfile mes deux bras
resté coincé dans la combinaison je suis
mince alors alors tout seul dans la
cabine gît bougeait pas et je me voyais
suivent le campo appelé personne je me
débrouille hommes tortillant tortillon
j'ai réussi à me dégager de la
combinaison ce jour là j'ai pas réussi à
mettre ma combinaison
si les essais de combinaisons étaient si
rares c'est parce qu'elles sont fragiles
et cher les essayer c'est prendre le
risque de les abîmer mais pour les
avocats des familles de victimes le
débat sur l'utilisation ou non des
combinaisons de sauvetage occulte la
recherche de responsabilités bien plus
importante des responsabilités sur la
conception du bateau
lorsqu'on regarde le rapport d'expertisé
on s'aperçoit que en raison précisément
de cette surdimension de de lusine par
rapport au bateau
la conception fait que
les ce qu'on appelle les vides déchets
c'est à dire en fait les trappes par
lesquels on évacue le poisson travailler
et non stockés sont très près du franc
bord le franc bord c'est en fait la
ligne de flottaison ce qui signifie qu'à
partir du moment où le bateau gîte de
façon un peu trop importante ce qui peut
arriver même dans des circonstances
normales l'eau peut embarquer par le
vide des chaînes c'est pas le premier on
en avait fait plat comme ça c'était
extrêmement 5 très rustique mais vous
savez en mer tout ce qui est rustique
c'est finalement beaucoup mieux que ce
qui est très sophistiqué et curieusement
les mardis on savait même pas qu'il y
avait un système avec un levier pour
fermer la petite trappe par laquelle les
déchets sont rejetés à la mer va peser
lourd dans l'histoire du snekkar arctic
au moment du naufrage le smicard
nordique jumeaux sortie des mets ma cm
navigue également en mer le troisième
navire identique le sne écart est
toujours sur cale en finition rapidement
après le drame ils subissent des
transformations pour les familles de
victimes c'est bien la preuve qu'il y
avait des défauts techniques à bord
le rapport d'expertisé nous apprend qu
effectivement à la suite du naufrage du
snekkar arctic des modifications sont
intervenues sur le store nordique
le retour à dieppe du snekkar nordique
quelques jours seulement après le
naufrage disney cars arc tic s'effectue
en toute discrétion
les chantiers ils ont préparé au niveau
des villes déchets une porte
adaptable
ouvrables de la passerelle avec une
commande de la passerelle mais ça je
suis après bien après
donc tout le monde peut se poser des
questions comment ça c'est que le bateau
a coulé ceci cela mais les chantiers
puis l'armement ils seraient ils ont
fait faire cette pièce là dans les
chantiers en kit et quand le bateau ils
ont fait rentrer il ya rentrée sur
quelques temps après quelques jours
après à 11 heures du soir il y avait des
journalistes où sa capsule qui ils ont
interdiction de monter à bord il ya
juste les gars du chantier qui sont
montés à bord avec leur leur nouveau
leurs nouvelles portes ils l'ont
installé ils ont fait monter les
commandes à la passerelle et puis tout à
7 heures du matin tout était installé
ni vu ni connu
et nous ont chargés de jours pourquoi
qu'on avait coulé on avait coulé par
l'unfp ils ont fait des transformations
terrible ils ont changé les ponts ils
ont
revue l'alimentation du tableau est très
petite à présent ils ont supprimé il
évite déchets ils ont mis à
l'hydraulique qu'on pouvait commander de
la passerelle et d'en bas ils ont mis
des années enfin ils en ont fait pour
vraiment une fortune de réparation de
ces modifications auraient pu passer
inaperçue
mais c'était sans compter sur la
solidarité des gens de la mer où le
hasard tout simplement
commenges hussein dey des années après
c'est au moins gisèle de trois ans à
près de
trois ans après par le par le gardien le
gardien du bateau qui m'a expliqué
s'agit que j'ai plus quoi que tu me l'as
pour 10.10 fallait que ce soit
confidentielles
en lui était comme gardien du bateau il
y à t amène de voir le travail qu'ils
ont fait pour vous dire les chantiers
savez l'armement savait aussi pourquoi
qu'on avait coulé mais nous savons pour
qui ont laissé les experts patauger
l' enquête sera aussi marquée par un
oubli volontaire de taille inexplicable
pas un rescapé ne sera entendu par le
juge alors même qu'ils sont les seuls à
pouvoir témoigner des circonstances du
drame
bateau aura écoulé gary boyd rescapés y
aura peut-être été aussi bien
les barras on comprend pas un bateau
neuf fleuron le rôle rock de la mer
comme il disait à tf1 pendant
l'instruction les affaires continuent
malgré les doutes sur la conception du
snekkar arctic un peu moins d'un an
après le naufrage en février 1987 les as
et m métallo le snekkar dernier des
trois bateaux identiques à être
construits dans ses chantiers
un ouvrier des chantiers livre ses
doutes devant une caméra de la presse
locale
non ça soleil bon moi y compris excuse
moi mais il penche sur la droite
sept ans d'instruction
les familles de victimes commencent à
trouver le temps long et se pose
désormais des questions sur le
fonctionnement de la justice
la rumeur court sur les quais de dieppe
le tribunal subir est il des pressions
pourquoi trois ans après le naufrage
l'armateur edouard leveaux n'at-il pas
été entendu par le juge est ce parce
qu'au même moment il entre en politique
et devient un influent conseiller
général du département il y avait ou
sable mou semblé t-il
des éléments troublants à titre
d'exemple si des mises en examens
multiples ont eu lieu l'administrateur
des affaires maritimes le bureau veritas
le constructeur du bateau en revanche
fort curieusement l'armateur du bateau
c'est à dire le propriétaire du bateau
n'avait pas été mis en examen n'avait
été entendu comme simple témoin qu'à la
toute fin de l'instruction et n'avait
pas été renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel
en fait l'armateur du bateau était une
personnalité tout à fait connu sur la
place de dieppe personnalités qui
avaient des engagements politiques et
cette place que cette personne tenait
dans la cité a probablement amené les
magistrats à prendre des précautions par
rapport à son éventuelle mise en cause
monsieur l'eau n'était plus aux yeux
d'un certain nombre de gens un simple
armateurs il est d'être un armateur
mais en même temps député ou maire de
dieppe ou ou engagés peu le preneur des
positions
politique la justice et au dessus des
pressions maintenant il est très clair
que lorsqu'on envisage de mettre en
cause une personnalité quand on est
magistrat probablement y réfléchiront à
deux fois
[Musique]
1993 sept ans après le drame le procès
que toute la ville de dieppe à temps a
enfin lieu sur le banc des accusés guy
roux directeur d'ea cm les chantiers qui
ont construit le nez car jean bourrel du
bureau veritas et henri poisson
administrateur des affaires maritimes
pour les familles les sept années
d'instruction qui laissait présager un
long procès débouche sur une mascarade
judiciaire
une seule journée d'audience une simple
journée d'audience pour sept ans de
procédure bratz a commencé à 9h
le fini à dix heures du soir
n'est pas aux abois pour aller à l'impro
16 laird
le à des avocats qui lui a
insulté l'équipage en disant que c'était
des propres ariana des pâtissiers
qui des deux bateaux
la colère de bernard mallet et relayé
par toutes les familles de victimes
les frères lecarpentier ont perdu leur
père marin sur le smicard arctique il
était adolescent
ils se sont constitués partie civile et
ont bien évidemment assister au procès
le typage était vraiment ça me lors de
lors de certaines plaidoirie avec
un avocat exercer son métier certes mais
où qui vraiment sa vie celle et les
membres d'équipage et c'était pas si
t'es pas tolérable d'ailleurs il ya eu
une ou deux fois où certains enfants de
marins se sont fait expulser puisque on
avait une envie c'était de réagir en
entendant ce qu'on entendait lors de
certaines peines étaient assez assez
difficile quinze jours plus tard le
verdict tombe c'est la relaxe pour tous
aussi bien pour les familles des
victimes que pour les accusés mais 18
morts des rescapés n'ont entendu des
questions non posées sur le naufrage
sont autant d'éléments qui renforcent la
détermination des familles de victimes
qu'on s'achemine vers un deuxième round
judiciaire
deux nouveaux avocats interviennent dans
le dossier comme benoît gruau du barreau
de paris le snekkar arctic et l'une de
ses premières affaires cette démission
1993 le tribunal correctionnel de dieppe
relaxe les trois prévenus le ministère
public fait appel et nous nous
retrouvons en 1995 devant la cour
d'appel de rouen chambre correctionnelle
le 15 mai 1995 la cour d'appel de rouen
rend sa décision
l'association des familles de victimes
reprend espoir
il y avait en réalité un partage de
responsabilités entre à la fois les
prévenus et l'équipage où on a considéré
à cette époque que l'équipage était
responsable en partie du naufrage
notamment à cause de la manoeuvre qui a
été fait par le capitaine est également
sur la question des gilets de sauvetage
où on a un moment donné reproché à ces
pauvres marin que de ne pas avoir mis
leur gilets de sauvetage attend 90 % de
fautes pour lady pâle et 90%
de fautes pour les chantiers le
navigation et ils ont condamné
le constructeur
à dix mille francs d'amendé et
l'administrateur qui avait donné le
permis de naviguer à dix mille francs
d'amendé aussi et tous les deux à six
mois de prison avec sursis
pour bernard mallet comme pour les
autres familles de victimes ce n'est pas
assez il faut continuer le combat et
saisir la cour de cassation c'est la
plus haute juridiction française elle ne
juge pas le fond de la faire mais statue
sur la forme la procédure au bout de
quelques mois elle rend ses conclusions
en 96
l'arrêt de la cour d'appel d'euros est
cassé pour preuve de deux procédures
mais qui est
là pour le coup assez exceptionnel
le magistrat de la cour d'appel qui a
rendu l'arrêt de la cour d'appel de roy
n'avait pas siégé d'une nullité de
procédure
l'histoire judiciaire du snekkar arctic
n'est pas avare en surprises la justice
se déclare incompétente a jugé un des
accusés en riz poisson l'administrateur
des affaires maritimes est un militaire
seul un tribunal militaire est apte à se
prononcer en riz poisson sort du procès
guy roux directeur d'ea cm et lui
reconnu coupable il est condamné à un an
de prison avec sursis et 30 mille francs
d'amendé 5000 euros
guy roux est seul pour répondre aux
chefs d'inculpation d'homicide
involontaire
quand il se pourvoit en cassation
la deuxième fois dans l'histoire
judiciaire du snekkar arctic c'est pour
jouer la montre d'hier et on en langage
sportif les avocats de guy roux se doute
qu'une nouvelle loi est en préparation
une loi qu'on pourrait croire fait sur
mesure il lui faut juste gagner du temps
l'intérêt aussi d'une bonne justice et
qu' il est difficile de rendre une
décision
sachant que la loi va changer
quelques mois après
et donc c'est une pratique qui existe la
cour de cassation
notamment sur des dossiers où il y à une
réforme sensible qui est en cours de
l'essai des notions suspens d'attendre
que la loi soit votée pour ensuite
statuer sur la nouvelle
cette nouvelle loi c'est la loi fauchon
déposée par le sénateur du même nom
adoptée le 10 juillet 2000 elle
amoindrit la responsabilité pénale dans
les délits non intentionnels et les
homicides involontaires
le destin de guy roux bénéficie d'un
sérieux coup de pouce
le 20 mars 2001 quinze ans après le
naufrage du snekkar arctic la justice
n'en a pas terminé avec cette affaire
la cour de cassation demande un renvoi
devant la cour d'appel de paris au même
moment le snekkar troisième bateau sorti
des chantiers à cm connaît des soucis en
mer il a chaviré
et
autres - y aller comme les autres il bat
tous les 19 h au marais qui l'a fait
rentrer à dieppe
décidément les smicards sont mal n'ai
aucun des trois bateaux sortis du même
moule dea cm n'échappe aux avaries à son
tour le snekkar nordique premier mise à
l'eau connaît des problèmes
immobilisé deux ans au bout de quai à
dieppe il est finalement revendue dans
un pays de l'est triste destin pour des
navires qu'ils devaient être des
fleurons de la pêche industrielle
française
le cours de la justice pour la faire du
snekkar arctic n'est pas glorieux non
plus la procédure n'en finit pas en 2003
la cour d'appel de paris appliquant les
effets de la loi fauchon adopté deux ans
plus tôt enlève toute responsabilité
pénale dans le naufrage au constructeur
guy roux
la cour d'appel de paris relaxant sur le
plan pénal donc des années après le
naufrage nous a renvoyés devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris
uniquement sur l'action civile
en 2006 vingt ans après le naufrage du
snekkar arctic les juges met enfin un
terme à la procédure pénale personne
n'est reconnu coupable mais pour les
familles des victimes il faut sauver
l'honneur des marrants
bernard mallet poursuit son combat sur
le plan civil cette fois le tribunal
civil ne statue que sur les dommages et
intérêts des plaignants il faut
recommencer à zéro
octobre 2008 enfin les dossiers vont
pouvoir être refermée la première
chambre de la cour d'appel de paris
l'une des plus prestigieuses de france
vient clore 22 ans de procédure bernard
mallet peut enfin levé les bras en signe
de victoire
[Musique]
l'appel de la délivrance des avocats de
bernard mallet la chambre civile de la
cour d'appel de paris a rendu son
délibéré dans un énième rebondissement
de la sphère du naufrage du snekkar
arctic en février 1986 la cour d'appel
reconnaît la responsabilité du
constructeur et condamne les assurances
l'association de familles du snekkar
avait fait appel en juin dernier après
avoir été débouté au civil est
incroyable
22h20 de référents était dans le vrai
bilan quarante trois plaignants sont
indemnisés les veuves de marins disparus
reçoivent 45000 euros les orphelins ou
les parents entre dix et quinze mille
euros un résultat au goût amer qui ne
remplacera jamais les maris les pères ou
les enfants disparus
[Musique]
la fin des smicards marque la fin d'une
époque pour 10 ap sa région
lézat cm dépose le bilan quelques années
après le naufrage tout comme l'armateur
edouard leveaux qui perdra également son
fauteuil de maire en 2008
le combat
les gens encore une fois je termine là
dessus
chez mal et qui contre vents et marées
le petit poucet tout seul le pot de
terre contre le pot de fer
la mémoire de son fils pour la mémoire
des marins et aller jusqu'au bout et
j'ai peut-être la réponse définitive à
votre question il faut quand même de
temps en temps voir la justice
bernard mallet a tenu parole il a mené
son combat jusqu'au bout pendant près
d'un quart de siècle pour son fils et
pour tous les marins disparus
on retrouvera un élément qui était son
élément il adorait la mer ils étaient
ils étaient fous de la mer
[Musique]
j'ai pensé
c'est un peu de lui
a beaucoup toujours quand vous avez y
est pas une journée ne fait pas penser à
me réveiller la nuit des fois bon bah je
pense
m
sur les hauteurs de dieppe le 21 février
une cérémonie rappelle qu'il ya
désormais un avant et un après snekkar
arctic
depuis le drame il y a eu d'autres
disparition en mer mais dorénavant les
combinaisons de sauvetage sont
systématiquement essayé par les marins
avant le départ la cérémonie rappelle
également que face à la justice face à
l'injustice
les combats des familles de victimes
mérite toujours d'être mené jusqu'au
bout